sieben Küchen Essentials von denen du
noch nicht weißt dass du sie brauchst
ein digitales Thermometer und
Temperaturen beim Frittieren oder
Kerntemperaturen zu messen damit könnt
ihr viele Fehler in der Küche
eliminieren ein scraper mit dem man
Sachen auf Schaden kann in Töpfe bewegen
kann oder auch zerteilt eine Microplane
oder eine vergleichbare reibe mit der
das Schreiben wirklich Spaß macht nicht
viel mit so einer stumpfen
supermarktreibe eine Salz Box mit der
man immer die perfekte Prise geben kann
und die sieht einfach besser aus als so
ein hässlicher Shaker ein guter scharfer
Sparschäler wird immer wirklich was
wegschälen kann kostet 2 3 € mehr aber
ist die Investition wirklich wert für
mich unfassbar wichtig ein Brett mit
Auffangschale so könnt ihr schnibbeln
und den Schnittabfall einfach unten ins
Fach geben und am Ende einmal wegwerfen
und zu guter Letzt meine planscher ich
habe das Gefühl seitdem ich das Ding
habe benutze ich keine Pfanne mehr
geiler sauber zu machen geilere
Temperaturkontrolle und falls ihr jetzt
sagt er das sind ja deine eigenen
Produkte genau das war mein Anspruch
Produkte zu machen die den Kochalltag
für jeden von euch ein bisschen besser
machen